ياتي ذلك على وقع خلافات اسرائيليه داخليه
مستمره حيث دع زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه
يائير لابيد وزراء حزب المعسكر في حكومه
الطوارئ الى الانسحاب من حكومه رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو لبيت قال خلال
جلسه لكتله حزبه في الكنيست ان الوزراء
غير مؤهلين لقياده الحرب وان نتنياهو غير
مؤهل لقياده الدوله على حد
تعبيره
ب
بني جانس ايزنكوت وجدعون ساعر عليكم ترك
هذه الحكومه فهي غير مؤهله لقياده الحرب
ونتنياهو غير مؤهل لقياده الدوله هذه
حكومه تحول فيها مجلس الوزراء الامني
المصغر الى ساحه تهجمات سامه على الجيش
حكومه تواصل في خضم الحرب تحويل المليارات
لاحزاب الائتلاف على نحو شائن حكومه ليس
لديها عمل سياسي ولا تعريف لهدف استراتيجي
للحرب هذه ليست حكومه وحده ولا حكومه
طوارئ وهم لا ينقذون اسرائيل انما ينقذون
نتنياهو من اجل جنودنا والسكان الذين
اجلوا من البلدات الحدوديه ومن اجل
مختطفين من غير المقبول ابقاء حكم بن كفير
وسيموت
وروك الى تلبيب مع مراسل الجزيره احمد
هزيم احمد مع وصول وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
الى تل ابيب كيف تستعد حكومه نتنياهو
لمواجهه المطالب الامريكيه بشان الحرب على
غزه نعم جلال اذا اخذنا ما سرب امريكيا عن
مسؤولين امريكيين لوسائل الاعلام امريكيه
عن المطالب الذي سياتي بلينك لطرحها على
الجانب الاسرائيلي وهي تتمثل في السماح
بعوده المدنيين الفلسطينيين الى شمال غزه
بعد ان اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي من انه دخله
هناك في شمال غزه الى المرحله الثالثه اي
مرحله تخفيض حده وكثافه العمليات العسكريه
والاكتفاء بعمليات نوعيه
محدده وبلينك جاء ليطلب من المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين الدخول او السماح للمدنيين
بالعوده الى هناك واذا اخذنا المطالب التي
تسربت ايضا حول وضع جداول زمنيه لنهايه
هذه الحرب
ومناقشه ما هي ما سيكون عليه شكل قطاع غزه
بعد انتهاء الحرب وما يعرف هنا اس
اسرائيليا باليوم التالي او سياسه او
استراتيجيه اليوم التالي فان الرد هنا
سواء ما سمعناه او ما تسرب عن الاجتماع
الوزاري عبر اكسيوس من القول بان اسرائيل
لن تسمح ل المدنيين الغزاويين بالعوده الى
شمال القطاع الا بعد ان توافق حماس على
اطلاق رهائن اسرائيليين اي بمعنى ان تدخل
حماس في صفقه عوده المدنيين مقابل اطلاق
مجموعه من الرهائن وفيما يتعلق بالدخول
الى مرحله او نهايه للحرب فالرد كان ايضا
في الاجتماع الذي دار بين بنيمين نتنياهو
ويوف جلاند وزير الدفاع والذي اعلن فيه
نتنياهو او قال فيه نتنياهو بان هذه الحرب
ستستمر وان المعركه ستستمر حتى تحقق
اهدافها من وجهه نظر اسرائيليه وان
المعركه في قطاع غزه ستستمر شهورا والموقف
الاسرائيلي المعلم من قبل رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو او حتى بعض وزرائه من
الائتلاف الحكومي ووزراء اقصى اليمين
الاسرائيلي مثل سموت ومثل بن كفير فان
الموقف هو ان تسيطر اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
امنيا وعسكريا وتبحث او او كما تسرب
للاعلام الاسرائيلي ان ان هناك بحث جار في
اسرائيل عن حمائم فلسطينيين يقومون با
بالدور الاداري لقطاع غزه
بينما تاخذ اسرائيل الحمل الامني والعسكري
وهو ما ترفضه الولايات المتحده نتذكر جلال
ان الولايات المتحده وعلى لسان اكثر من
مسؤول من بينهم ر وزير الخارجيه انتوني
بلينكن كانت عنده عنده كانوا قد اعلنوا ع
لاءات لا لتقليص حجم القطاع غزه لا
للتهجير القصري ولا
ل لاعاده احتلال قطاع غزه وهي ه هذت
اللاءات الثلاث كلها عرضها بنيامين
نتنياهو
وعرضها بنفير وسموت فهم يريدون وضع شريط
امني حدودي يفصل بين قطاع غزه ومستوطنات
وبلدات غلاف غزه يريدون وضع تقسيم قزه
لثلاث مناطق عسكريه منطقه سيطره عسكريه
وامنيه واداريه من قبل اسرائيل ومنطقه
عمليات محدوده نوعيه ومنطقه منطقه امنه
للمدنيين ف بلينكن لديه مهمه صعبه في
اقناع الجانب الاسرائيلي بالمطالب
الامريكيه شكرا لك احمد في تل ابيب